es septiembre de 2008 hay un pequeño
pueblecito en el norte de alaska que se
llama capto bit que está en el círculo
polar ártico donde está comenzando el
invierno los esquimales que viven allí
siempre han vivido pues de las pieles de
oso polar de la caza de la pesca unos
años antes descubren que debajo del
hielo tienen enormes cantidades de
petróleo y ese año 2008 la candidata
republicana la casa blanca sarah pailin
decide que ese petróleo se tiene que
comercializar convierte este tema en una
de las polémicas de la campaña así que
allí estábamos mi cámara y yo haciendo
un reportaje sobre capto bit
prácticamente aislados solamente
teníamos una llamada que hacíamos desde
un teléfono fijo en un albergue donde
dormíamos por las noches para comprobar
con madrid' que todo estaba bien
ese día la llamada fue de la siguiente
manera qué tal cómo estás
hola carlos necesitamos que hagas un
directo desde nueva york dentro de 4
horas
carmen estamos en alaska bueno bien de
acuerdo pero puedes volver a nueva york
cuánto tiempo tardaría en llegar a nueva
york no sé 23 horas 23 días esto está
muy lejos estamos completamente aislados
pero
sabes lo que ha pasado no qué es lo que
ha pasado acaba de hundirse lehman
brothers la bolsa está por los suelos y
no sabemos qué consecuencias va a tener
todo esto oops la noticia que iba a
marcar los próximos 10 años la noticia
del año desde luego y nosotros estábamos
completamente aislados en un pueblo de
alaska sin poder hacer prácticamente
nada bueno puede parecer que la peor
forma o la manera más radical de
aislarse para poder informar para poder
transmitir contenido para poder hacer
buen periodismo es estar eso en un
pequeño pueblo alejado de todo
desconectado del mundo y que eso es lo
que impide realmente hacer información
realmente esto es así pero es anecdótico
hoy en las sociedades en las que estamos
de súper información hay cinco elementos
que son los que definen verdaderamente
cuándo podemos y cuando no podemos hacer
buena información el primer elemento
tristemente pero es verdad para poder
informar bien es el dinero los grandes
medios de comunicación son normalmente
empresas privadas tienen cuentas de
resultados
en consejos de administración y
necesitan beneficios para poder pagar
las redacciones que trabajan en ellos
hoy ese dinero es uno de los grandes
condicionantes hasta hace poco el
problema estaba más o menos bien
resuelto con una cosa que se llamaba la
publicidad los periódicos tenían decenas
y decenas de páginas de publicidad y en
las televisiones también había
muchísimos anuncios hoy mirad los
periódicos que habéis comprado si los
habéis comprado cuántos páginas de
publicidad tienen de hecho mirar cuántos
quioscos hay en vuestros barrios para
poder comprar los periódicos y la prensa
escrita desciende de sus ventas entre un
10 15 por ciento cada año de forma
irremediable y es verdad que la tele
sigue habiendo muchos anuncios pero las
grandes empresas se empiezan a dar
cuenta que los más jóvenes no veis ya la
televisión con lo cual no hay dinero
esto qué quiere decir hay futuro no hay
futuro si hay futuro y además tiene el
nombre de una palabra netflix de repente
hemos descubierto qué
somos capaces de pagar una pequeña
cantidad de dinero por entretenimiento
bueno pues ese esquema vamos a ver cómo
se va a trasladar dentro de muy poco
tiempo a las grandes cabeceras de medios
de comunicación de hecho en 2019 todas
las grandes cabeceras de periódico de
españa van a empezar a probar métodos de
pago una pequeña suscripción por recibir
información es algo que está ahí que va
a pasar y que además tiene un camino de
éxito que está ya comprobado en nosotros
nos estamos mirando constantemente en el
ejemplo de un diario el 'new york times'
lleva siete años haciendo ese ejercicio
y hoy por hoy ha conseguido ya tres
millones de suscriptores y más cantidad
de ingresos por lo que les llega de esos
suscriptores que por lo que son los
métodos tradicionales de ingresos para
un periódico segundo elemento la
organización olvidaros de esa imagen
romántica del periodista que está por
las noches fumando bebiendo escribiendo
en un papel de una forma un tanto
desesperada y aislada todo eso ha
cambiado completamente hoy
y la información viaja a velocidades
vertiginosas hay toneladas y toneladas
de contenido que tenemos que gestionar
es un poco como si estuviésemos en un
río en el que hay muchísima corriente y
vamos en kayak y tenemos que manejarlo
con muchísima precisión para no caernos
bueno todo eso hace que la maquinaria de
un medio de comunicación tenga que estar
perfectamente organizada el periodista
hoy ya no solamente escribe o produce
contenidos sino que tiene que saber
también cómo distribuirlo en sus redes
sociales en sus canales de youtube
cómo se relaciona también con todos los
lectores o con todos los espectadores
que interactúan con él a base de
mensajes directos todo eso está ahí y no
solamente en lo que somos los
periodistas que producimos información
también las empresas o los políticos han
experimentado una organización
extremadamente acelerada una mercado
como por ejemplo redbull que
probablemente hace 10-12 años cada vez
que tuviese que emitir un mensaje haría
un comunicado de prensa hoy ha cambiado
completamente sus estructuras hoy tiene
ya una redacción de periodistas y no
solamente eso sino que tiene
propios canales de televisión sus
propias publicaciones para emitir los
mensajes que quiere tercer elemento la
formación sigue siendo básica pero ojo
porque aquí no hablamos de la formación
universitaria que sigue siendo también
muy importante sino la formación que
recibimos antes la que tienen los
chavales en los colegios es muy
interesante ahí ver cómo son las
diferentes experiencias en los distintos
países en eeuu por ejemplo a los
chavales desde muy pequeños en los
colegios les enseñan retórica cómo
hablar en público cómo enfrentarse bien
a un auditorio como este eso con los
años se traduce en unos medios de
comunicación que son muy ágiles que
pueden sintetizar muy bien los mensajes
que van a un ritmo trepidante es más si
veis cualquier documental o cualquier
noticia de una academia de televisión
americana os daréis cuenta que desde el
granjero de kentucky hasta el
informático de california o el
científico de houston
todos saben frente a una cámara lanzar
mensajes en 1520 segundos que se pueden
entender son perfectos para la
televisión en cambio en alemania es
distinto la información es mucho más
pesa mucho más teórica mucho más
reflexiva todo eso luego se traslada
también a la forma como hacen periodismo
los presentadores de televisión son
estáticos son casi como bustos parlantes
sin sentimientos transmiten los mensajes
de una forma súper seria es noticia y
esto lo digo porque es real el día que
deciden después de muchos años cambiar
la mesa del telediario por una diferente
y eso se convierte en noticia porque es
algo que es completamente inamovible y
en la prensa escrita pasa un poco lo
mismo el lenguaje que utilizan es muy
técnico es muy elaborado no tiene nada
que ver con el lenguaje que utilizan en
la calle los alemanes es una cosa mucho
más densa
la formación sirve también de
entrenamiento para el cuarto de los
elementos el talento hay parte del
talento que puede que sea innato yo creo
que todo el talento se entrena pero
demos por hecho que parte de ese talento
viene con la persona
la otra gran parte ese talento es un
entrenamiento que se lleva a cabo a
través de la formación y a través de la
experiencia es un talento que ha
cambiado mucho también en lo que
trabajamos en medios de comunicación no
se trata ya tanto de detectar dónde está
la historia de cómo contarla sino que
ahora vivimos en ese mundo del río con
la corriente tan fuerte en la que
tenemos que ver también cuál es lo que
no es historia lo que venimos llamando
fake news que ahora vamos a empezar a
llamar noticias basura hay un torrente
enorme y enorme de información que no es
real que tenemos que controlar y el
quinto elemento básico también la
tecnología que lo ha cambiado
absolutamente todo hoy en estos
aparatitos que tenemos en el bolsillo
tenemos más tecnología que toda la que
se utilizó para llevar el hombre a la
luna gran parte de la tecnología que
encierran estos teléfonos la utilizamos
para entretenernos pero también para
informarnos eso nos ha cambiado
completamente el escenario también a los
periodistas si pudiésemos trasladarnos a
la redacción del país ahora mismo vería
es como el centro de la redacción que
hace unos años estaba llena de
periodistas hoy la ocupan otros perfiles
diseñadores webs
desarrolladores del lenguaje informático
de técnicos
técnicos de analítica expertos en redes
sociales todos ellos trabajan
desarrollan contenidos de la mano de los
periodistas que trabajan también en esa
redacción esa tecnología nos está
llevando además a fronteras
completamente desconocidas la próxima
que tenemos es qué hacer con la
inteligencia artificial cómo trabajar
con los algoritmos hasta donde los
queremos llevar ahí vamos a tener dos
opciones que los robots sean robots que
trabajen con nosotros y que trabajen
para nosotros o que los robots sean
elementos que sustituyan el trabajo que
nosotros hacemos en ese debate estamos
yo opto por la primera opción pero ya
hay experimentos que optan por la
segunda fijaos bien lo que están
haciendo por ejemplo los chinos wang en
inglés artificial intelligence and que
éste es my baby face the end the world
ends y my voice
el referente hermano de alejandro riline
continua deliberadamente de media en
estrictos porque antonio elevation en de
integración de international evans
technologies el water las de egipto en
forma esta extrovertido demás están
adentro apt el power point break news
experiencias tuve cuando un conjunto de
ángel o incluso de no introducir el hoyo
todos son un saliente además inclusión y
en la estación 48
buenos robots que parecen humanos
humanos que parecen robots hay que saber
con qué nos vamos a quedar en el futuro
pero ese futuro está ahí ahora vosotros
ya os toca decidir si lo que hayáis
visto si yo soy un robot soy de verdad
os incluso vosotros también sois un
algoritmo que me estáis escuchando o soy
verdaderamente seres humanos gracias
[Aplausos]